if you're in this part of show business
where you're in the Iron Man franchise
and you're in the Avengers it's got to
get intense with paparazzi it can be I
mean you have to pick your spots and you
know you kind of know where there are
and when you're gonna try to avoid them
and stuff and actually it was a it was
it was big now but it was even bigger
during the Ocean's eleven during all of
those movies oh really
yeah with George and Matt and and and
Brad and I remember one time Matt was
coming to my house he called me up and
he said hey man I got picked up a tail I
got these paparazzi behind me I was like
well you're Jason Bourne lose him
yeah you said I got my kids in the car
he's like well I got to try to lose him
and I'll get to your house when I can
and so he come he finally gets to the
house and knocked on the door he runs in
his kids are all under blankets or
whatever he comes in the house
he said I actually got lost because I
live in an area that's a little tucked
away he said he got lost and he thought
he'd lost him he's driving around he
went around the corner and they were
just parked on the street they were like
down there right the paparazzi knows
where you live they're telling him Matt
it no no this is where you want to go
yeah right third house on the left yeah
that's fantastic yeah it was great
they're quite helpful